So, we were talking about expected values,
right, averages, linearity.
So, just continuing
right where we left off.
I owe you a proof of linearity.
I don't like be in debt, so
let's start by proving linearity, and
then do some more examples.
We started on some examples last time, but
continue just seeing why is linearity so
useful, linearity of expectation.
So start with the proof.
This is kind of my own proof of linearity.
I call it, I don't know what I call it.
But I like this proof better than
the ones that usually one sees.
Basically, remember last time we
wrote down a list of numbers, and
we averaged them in two different ways?
One is the naive way, just add them up and
divide by how many numbers there are, and
then the other way was we grouped the same
numbers together, grouped them together,
and take the weighted
average at the same thing.
That's basically the proof of linearity,
it just doesn't seem that way until
you think hard enough about it.
So I wanna explain that point
of view to you rather than doing
tedious calculations.
So here's what we're trying to do.
We're looking at the sum of two random
variables, let's call it T for total,
T = X+Y, and our goal is to show
that expected value of T is the expected
value of X plus the expected value of Y.
Show E(T) = E(X)+E(Y),
which as I said last time, is pretty
obvious if X and Y are independent, but
not at all obvious, at least to most
people, if X and Y are dependent, and
this is always true as long
as these expectations exist.
You could have random variables where
the expectation doesn't exist, cuz the sum
diverges, or something like that, but
as long as these numbers actually exist,
this is always true,
even if they're dependent.
So here's kind of the first attempt.
What if we just tried
to directly prove this?
It looks kind of straightforward,
and you can say,
well sums are linear, and so
on, it should be kind of easy.
Let's just try to do this brute
force from the definition.
What would we have to do?
Well, we'd have to write
down the definition of E(T),
the definition of E(X), the definition
of E(Y), and see is it the same.
So here's E(T).
E(T) is the sum over t, right now,
I'm assuming they're discrete.
I'm gonna prove it in the discrete case.
We haven't dealt much yet
with continuous random variables, but
we'll be coming to that soon.
But the proof is analogous in
the continuous case anyway.
So right now we're working with
discrete random variables.
That means we have a PMF, and the expected
value is the sum of of T times the PMF so
remember this form also time.
We're just taking a weighted average of,
little t is a possible value of capital T,
and that's the PMF, so
it's just the weighted average.
So, but equals with a question mark,
because this is what we wanna see,
whether this is true, E(X)+E(Y).
So for E(X) we would take the sum of x,
sum over xP(X=x), and
then similarly for y, yP(Y=y).
I'm assuming they're all discrete random
variables, so we can work with the PMFs.
So there's a question mark here.
So now we need some kind of a strategy.
How do we deal with this?
Well, I guess there's two strategies I
can think of just off the top of my head.
One would be try to mess around
with the right hand side, and
show that equals this.
The other be we try to
mess around with this, and
show that it can split it up like that.
Let's consider both strategies.
Strategy one,
try to combine these into this.
This is a sum over x,
this is a sum over a y.
How do we combine a sum over x and
a sum over y?
Just like two sums right, I don't
really see how to put them together.
So let's consider
the alternative approach.
Take this thing,
now how can we break this apart?
Well this is a little bit more promising.
I mean, it's not obvious like how
is t gonna split up into an x and
a y, but we can try to play
around with this P(T=t).
In particular, we could take P(T=t), and
our most important strategy
is conditioning, right?
What do we wish we knew?
Well, it would be useful to know X, or
to know Y, so it's conditioned on X.
So I can write this as
the sum over little x, P(T=t
| X=x)P(X=x).
Now T,
capital T = X+Y, and if we know X is
little X we can plug in little X there.
If X and Y are independent then
we could simplify this, and
it'd be kind of similar to when we
proved algebraically that the sum
of independent binomials
with the same P is binomial.
We did the algebraic proof of that.
It reduced to the Vandermonde thing.
So it will look kind of like that if X and
Y are independent, and
we could eventually probably
work it out to this.
Now that's if X and Y are independent,
but I didn't say X and Y are independent.
So if they're dependent then you're
just kind of stuck with this given
(X=x) forever.
You can plug in (X=x), but
there's still gonna be a y here,
and then it's y given x, and your stuck.
So, that doesn't work.
Let's do this from another point of view.
But just by looking at
pebble world over here.
So, I'm just gonna draw a simple picture.
Let's just suppose X has four
possible values, and I just assume
that I've arranged my sample space such
that they're kind of arranged by column.
Remember a random variable is
a mapping from the sample space.
The sample space is the set of
all pebbles to the real line.
So suppose I've arranged my pebbles,
just for simplicity in that picture I'm
assuming X can only take on
these four possible values, but
the same idea would work for
any discrete random variable.
Let's just have a picture
I can draw easily.
So suppose that there are four pebbles,
each of these pebbles get mapped X=0, so
that means you have this random
experiment if the outcome is one
of these four pebbles, then we say X=0.
If the outcome is one of these
two pebbles, we say X=1, and
maybe these three pebbles go to X=2,
and this one pebble goes to X=3.
So that's what a random variable is.
Any discrete random variable,
conceptually, looks something like this.
Now let's just make an observation
about how we can do our summation,
E(X), we defined it to be the sum
over all values x of x times the PMF.
That was the definition, but notice that
we could do this a different way instead.
That is to sum, not over values of the
random variable, but sum over all pebbles.
So this is the space capital S, and
I'm thinking of each individual
pebble as a lower case s.
X(s) remember x is a function,
so X(s)P(s).
Remember we have these different
pebbles whose total mass equals 1.
P(s) is the mass of pebble s.
So, notice this is the same thing, and
that's obvious once you've stared at it
enough to like understand what we're doing
here, because it's the same thing as
doing the average in two different ways,
like we did last time.
This one is the grouped one.
This one is the ungrouped.
So what we're doing with this some
of our pebbles is we're just taking
each pebble as a sign of certain value and
we're just averaging them all together.
It's a very obvious thing to do.
Just take the average, of course it's
a weighted average cuz some of the pebbles
have higher probability possibly.
On the other hand as in this picture
we could first group together all
the pebbles that got
assigned X equals to 0,
group together that's assign
X equals to 1 and so on.
Group all these together.
You can imagine these four
pebbles with X equals 0,
kind of like clump them together, glue
them together, until like a super pebble.
A super pebble has a mass equal
to the sum of these masses.
Glue these two together, glue these three
together, this one's already one pebble.
So we could group them together, that's
exactly what this is saying to do, right,
because we grouped them all together, and
then give it a larger mass,
if it's a super pebble.
So that's just immediate, just by
thinking of how we could do averages by
grouping together terms
that have the same value.
So that's true for any random variable X.
Now, let's probe linearity
in the discrete case.
And the continuous case
is basically the same.
We'll talk more about continuous later.
So what do we have to do?
Well, let's just use this same
identity for T instead of for X.
So we could say well what's
the probability, not the probability.
What's the expected value of T?
This definition got us
stuck let's use this way
to write as a sum of overall pebbles.
So it's the sum overall
s X plus Y of s P of s.
By definition what does it
mean to add two functions?
Well, it just means you compute
both functions and add them.
That's just the definition
of adding functions.
So, that's really just the same thing
as X of s, plus Y of s, times P of s.
And now, just distribute, you know,
this times this, plus this times this.
And break the sum.
Now everything is summed over the same s,
whereas here it was annoying,
cuz we had to sum over x, sum over y.
Here, everything is a sum over pebbles.
So now we just write it as two sums,
that's just the sum of X of s P of
s plus the sum of Y of s, P of s.
But according to this identity again
that's just E of X plus E of Y.
And so that's the end of the proof.
So it's almost immediate once you see
that you can write the expected value as
the sum of pebbles rather
than in this original form.
Okay, well now I have a clear
conscience about linearity.
There was one other fact about linearity,
which was that you can
multiply by constants.
So I'll just say similarly,
do the exact same thing except
it's even easier in this case
if we multiply it by a constant,
E of C times X equals C times
E of X if C is a constant.
That's the other part of linearity.
And to see that,
just use the same thing again.
Just multiply both sides by C,
take out the C.
This one is more intuitive, I think,
because it just says, you know,
the expected value of 2 times X is
twice the expected value of X so
we use that a lot.
But by the way actually, this one I think
this seems pretty simple if you multiply
all the numbers by three then multiply
the average by three, it's pretty natural.
But this also helps explain
some of the intuition for
why is this true even if X and
Y are dependent.
Because remember it's very useful
to look at extreme cases, so
here is an extreme case of dependence,
What if X equals Y?
That's as dependent as they can get.
They're the same thing.
Now if that's true,
then E of X plus Y since
it's the same thing it's
E of 2X equals 2 E of X,
which is in fact the same
thing as E of X plus E of Y.
Okay, so that's not a proof of linearity,
but that's checking.
That in that extreme form of dependence,
it's true.
And in the case of independence then it's
pretty intuitive that this should be true
and so we've covered both extremes and
the proof covers everything in between.
So that linearity.
So let's do some more examples
of how we would use that.
Here's another one of our
famous distributions, and we're
gonna have a whole, by the end of this
semester we're gonna have a list of 13 or
14 extremely important
distributions in statistics.
So you might ask,
what makes a distribution important,
because there are infinitely
made distributions so
we could write down just
choose whatever PMF we want.
Or create any CDF we want and
then at some distribution and
why are we being so undemocratic about it
and we keep talking about binomials and
geometrics or we could be talking,
everyone can make up their own.
Well, the reason is that
the most important ones all have
nice useful stories behind them.
So we saw the story of the binomial
the story of the geometric the story of
the hyper geometric and there's just a few
more of those that we're gonna need soon.
There are only a couple more discrete
ones we need for the entire semester.
And then there's gonna be a bunch of
continuous ones that we'll get to later.
But as far s discrete ones, I think
there's only two more that we need.
So, I'll do one today,
and one on Wednesday.
And then we're done with
all the famous discrete
distributions that we need in this course.
So one of them is called
the negative binomial.
Don't be fooled by the name,
the name negative binomial usually might
make you think that you take
a binomial and then make it negative.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Like multiply it by negative 1 or
something.
But negative binomial is actually non
negative and it's not a binomial.
So it's kind of a mis-normal but
that's standard terminology.
Actually what the negative binomial is,
is a generalization of
the geometric distribution.
So a negative binomial,
it has two parameters Of r and p.
And the story is that,
remember what the geometric.
We were doing Bernoulli trials over and
over and over again
until getting success for the first time
then we counted the number of failures.
This is the extension to the case
where you want r successes.
So again we have independent
Bernoulli P trials,
like with the geometric.
And we want to know number of Of failures,
Before the rth success.
So keep trying and trying and
trying until you have r successes, and
then count the number of failures.
That value would be called
a negative binomial.
And, Let's find the PMF.
Let's find the expected value, okay?
So what's the PMF?
Well, to find the PMF basically we
just need to draw a little picture for
ourselves, and
then think about the picture.
So the picture is just a sequence.
Well, let's write 1 for
success and 0 for failure.
So maybe it looks like this, 1000100,
I'm just making something up right now.
And let's choose a value of r,
let's say r equals 5, 00001001.
Okay, I just made up a sequence
that has five 1s in it and
however many 0s,
I just felt like writing, okay.
Now [COUGH], I claim that if we
stare at this binary sequence
long enough we can just write down the PMF
without having to do any further work.
So that's good, I don't wanna do a lot of
work, I just wanna write down the PMF.
So what's the PMF?
Well, I say you just stare at this,
I mean we all need to stare at this a bit.
I'm saying that r = 5,
just for our sake of example,
because I drew five 1s, r = 5.
And well, I guess I have to
do some work counting the 0s.
How many 0s were there?
One, two, three four five six
seven eight nine, eleven 0s.
So we want the probability that x = n,
let's say if x is negative binomial.
x equals n would me that
there are 11 failures, right.
So since there are 11 ones,
n = 11 in this example, okay?
And p is whatever it is,
we don't have to worry about p right now.
All right now, Notice one simple but
important fact about this
sequence that ends in a 1, right?
That's the rth success right there.
Okay?
That could not have been a 0, right?
Because if that was a 0 that would either
mean we had not yet achieved our rth
success, or we'd achieved it earlier and
then why were we continuing, okay?
So one thing I know for
sure, is that when you stop this,
it's gonna be with a success, right?
Now, let's consider
the rest of this stuff.
If I permute these 0s and 1s,
would that still be valid?
Yeah, it didn't matter, right?
And I can change these however I want, so
amongst here, there are four successes,
meaning we have not yet
got in our fifth success.
So permute these however you want,
it's not gonna change things.
It's not gonna change the probability,
it's not gonna change
whether it's valid or not.
So amongst these earlier terms,
we know that there are 4 successes and
11 failures, right?
But those can be in any order.
And those are the only possibilities,
right?
We need to have the rth success,
and then the earlier stuff.
We already know how many 0s,
how many 1s it could be but
they could be in any order, okay.
Now we can immediately write down the PMF.
The PMF is gonna be, first of all the
probability of this particular sequence,
this particular sequence had r successes,
and each success has probability p.
And there are n failures,
so it's (1- p) to the n.
That's the probability of this
particular sequence that I wrote down.
Then we have to multiply
it by how many possible
ways are there are to rearrange it.
This one has to stay here,
but the ones before it,
the terms before it could be in any order.
So all we have to do is select
the locations of the 0s, or
equivalently select
the locations of the 1s.
So we can do,
how many terms are there before?
Well it's n + r- 1,
just everything except the last one.
And then we just have to choose where
the successes are, there's r- 1 successes.
So we could do r- 1.
We could also chose n,
remember it's the same thing.
So this is for n = 0,1,2, and so on.
So that's the PMF.
The reason it has the name negative
binomial is just that in combinatorics
this kind of series is closely related to
what you would get if we did the binomial
theorem.
The binomial theorem is
a plus b to a positive power,
if you expand a plus b to a negative power
you get something closely related to this.
So it's like a negative power
in the binomial theorem.
But that's just the etymology of the term
and we don't need to worry about that.
For our purposes what we care about is
the story and we care about the PMF.
And then we care about
what can we do with this?
Well, The next
obvious thing to do is compute the mean,
right?
So let's find E (X),
Okay, so we have the PMF, so
in principle we can compute
the mean just by taking the sum of
n times this, summed over all n.
And that looks pretty nasty.
So let's try to think of
a better way to do it.
Better way to do this is to say well,
first of all if r is 1,
remember think of simple in extreme cases.
If r equals 1 then it's just a geometric
and we computed last time in two different
ways that a geometric p has
expected value q over p, okay?
So we know the case r equals 1 already.
Now let's think, okay, well it's
a slightly harder case, r equals 2.
So we are waiting and waiting and
waiting, until we have two successes.
But a natural way to view that would be,
first you wait for
your first success, and then you wait for
the second success, right?
And in general if you wanna wait for
r successes, you can think of that as,
first wait for the first success, then
wait for the second, third and the fourth.
So therefore we can interpret this as,
I'm gonna rewrite X as X1 + blah, blah,
blah + Xr,
where Xj is the number of failures.
X1 is the number of failures
before the first success.
X2 is the number of failures between the
first success and the second success and
so on.
So Xj is number of failures between
(j- 1)st and jth successes.
For X1, I'm just interpreting
it as the number of failures
to start with before the first success.
So number of Failures between
the j minus first and jth success.
Then we already know the distribution
of Xj, Xj is just geometric p.
Now in this case the extras
are even independent, but
we don't even need that for
this calculation.
So, they're independent because if you
just imaging we have independent trials.
So you wait an amount of time for
the first success.
And then I'm talking about the additional.
From that point on we're starting
at that point, how many more?
And keep going like that.
So they are independent,
but we don't actually care.
By linearity this is
just E of X1 plus blah,
blah, blah, plus E of Xr,
therefore that's equal to rq over p.
So that's another calculation you could
do in your head because in your head
you just think, well I'll wait for the
first success and then the additional for
the second and
the additional for the third.
Each one of those is geometric P.
Each one of those q over p and
there's r of them, so it's rq over p.
We just took q over p and
multiplied it by r.
So it's very, very easy if you
think of it that way and very,
very nasty if you don't
think of it that way.
Okay, so, that's the negative binomial.
And I want to just mention that you do
have to be careful about conventions,
both for the geometric and
the negative binomial.
Some books start the geometric at 1, which
would mean you're counting the success.
And we are starting it at,
both conventions are common,
starting it at 0 or starting at 1.
They're both very common
in the literature.
For example Ross starts
his geometrics at one.
And starts his geometrics at zero.
And we're starting our geometrics at zero.
So we're following more
like the convention
which again is very common as well but
both conventions are common.
For the geometric, I'm kind of ambivalent
about which convention I like more.
But I decided to go with the zero.
The negative binomial.I definitely
like the convention more.
If you look in Ross he'll start
the negative binomial at r,
because he's counting
the successes as well, so
if if you're successful the first r times,
then those would count.
And we're starting at zero.
So it's very easy to convert back and
forth between those, it's just you have to
be careful, if you just blindly
copy a formula from somewhere, and
they're using a different convention,
then it's gonna be completely wrong.
As long as you're careful,
then it's not really a big deal.
Just to say a little bit more
about that geometric thing.
Let's define what is sometimes called
the first success distribution.
Let's let X.
X be FS of p, that's first success of p,
that is the time until first success.
So we are going to have
these Bernoulli trials.
And this one is counting the success.
Just because I have noticed that sometimes
student get confused about how to convert
back and forth and it should be very easy.
So once you've thought it a little bit
hopefully it will be easy to do that.
So this is, so if we just write geometric
we're not counting the success.
If we write FS of p then
we're counting the success.
S for success.
Okay?
Well, if we wanted to
deal with this problem
we don't need to go through
a new theory and everything.
All we have to do is say, well let's just
let, if we want to deal with such an X,
all we would do is just
let Y equal X minus 1.
Then, by our definition, Y is geometric p
I subtracted 1,
just cuz I don't wanna count the success.
That's all.
And so then it's easy to relate
the two PMFs because if we wanna know
the probability that X equals something,
just rewrite that in terms of Y.
That's very easy.
And if we want the expected value of X,
the expected value of X.
Well, X is Y plus 1.
So it's just E of Y plus 1.
And by the way,
it's fairly common to omit,
I'll write the parentheses for now, but
it's fairly common in the literature to
omit the parentheses with expected
value when there's not ambiguity.
Expected value of Y is q over p.
So this is q over p plus 1.
Which we can simplify by getting
a common denominator, p plus q is 1.
So that's just 1 over P.
So that's a pretty nice result too.
A very simple looking formula for the
expected value of the first success time
and 1 over P, this is pretty
intuitive when you think about it.
Let's see what that says.
Suppose that our probability
of success is 1 in 10.
Then it says, on average, it would take
ten trials to get the first success,
if you include that success.
So that kinda makes sense,
if you succeed one in ten times,
it means it's gonna take about ten trials.
So that's all it's saying.
Okay so that's just how you
convert between those things.
Okay so that's the negative
binomial distribution, and
then that only leaves you one more famous
discrete distribution that we'll need and
we'll save that for next time.
First I wanted to do a couple
more examples with expectation.
So here's another problem I really like.
That is, this is a problem that came
from Putnam exam a few years ago.
So for
those of you who don't know the Putnam is
one of the hardest math
competitions in the country.
It's extremely difficult math exam,
and it's offered every year.
Most year, the medium score on the Putnam
is a zero because most people who
take it can't solve any of the questions,
so they get zeros.
So it's a very hard, hard exam, and
here is a problem that came
straight off the Putnam.
I like this problem because it
illustrates what we're doing,
and we can solve this problem very
easily with what we're doing.
Okay, so here's the problem.
The problem says you
have a random permutation
of the numbers integers from 1 to n.
So, in general they don't have
a lot of probability on the Putnam,
but they do occasionally have probability.
Especially when it's actually counting.
That is, you could use the naive
definition of probability.
Although, that would actually
not be a good idea here.
So by random they mean that all
permutations are equally likely.
So we take the numbers 1 through n and
permute them in any order.
All n factorial equally likely.
And let's assume n is at least two,
to avoid some stupid cases.
Now, I have to tell you
what the question is.
The question is find the average, or
expected number, of local maxima.
So I have to tell you
what a local maximum is.
Expected number, so
this is all defined on the problem.
And this is exactly what the problem was,
I'm just phrasing it in my own words, but
this is exactly the problem.
Find the expected number of local maxima.
And it's easiest to explain what local
maxima is just by making up an example.
So I'll just permute some numbers,
let's say we had.
3214756.
So, that's a permutation of 1 through 7.
Local maxima is any number that's
bigger than its neighbors.
So 7,
I'm going to circle the local maxima.
7 is bigger than 4 and 5.
Now, the 3 only has one neighbor,
the 2, cuz that's at the endpoint.
But 3 is bigger than 2,
so that still counts.
So there's two different types.
Either you can have one that's in
the middle somewhere and then it has to be
bigger than both its neighbors, or you can
have one at the end, 6 is bigger than 5.
So in this example,
you can make up whatever example you want.
In this example, it happened that
both endpoints are local maxima.
And one point in the middle
was a local maxima.
And none of these are local maxima.
Does everyone understand the problem now?
So you want to know on average this is
one of 7 profactorial things I could have
written down and on along average
how many local maxima are there.
So, actually,
not only was that a Putnam problem, but
I was kind of like looking
around on some Putnam
forums a couple years ago when people
were discussing that year's Putnam.
A lot of people who took the exams
thought these were the hardest questions
on that year's exam.
So, now, let's solve the problem.
So first of all we need some
indicator random variables,
so let's let Ij be the indicator
random variable for
a position j being a local maxima.
So, of position j,
this is position one, two, three and so
on position j either it does,
right that's an event, either it does or
it does not have a local
maxima at that position.
So that's what we are looking at.
Position j having a local max,
so that's a natural indicator
random variable to look at.
And of course Ij goes from 1 to n.
Now the sum of these
Ij is the number of local maxima.
That's what we're trying to count.
So what we're interested in
is the expected value of I1
plus blah blah blah plus In and
by linearity,
that's just E of I1 plus
E of I2 plus E of In.
Now the only thing or
the main thing we have to be careful about
here is to split into two different cases.
One is that because we have these
endpoints and we have these non-endpoints.
So we do have symmetry,
in the sense that what was the probability
that this number here, which happens to be
a 7, is bigger than both its neighbors?
Well, if you look at these
three positions here, the 4,
the 7 and the 5 by symmetry,
they're equally, likely to be in
any of the six possible orders.
And at those six orders there's two ways
that the biggest could be in the middle.
So it could have been 475 or 574.
Two over six is one-third.
Or an even better way
to think of it is that
we're looking at these
three positions here.
The largest number among those three is
equally likely to be in any
of those three positions.
The 7 was equally likely to have
been there, there, or there.
So there's a one third chance that
the biggest number is in the middle.
A common mistake with this would
be to say it's one-fourth.
Because there's a 50-50 chance that
this number is bigger than this number.
And there's a 50% chance that this
number is bigger than this number.
And so
a lot of people would say one-fourth here.
That's the same mistake as,
you remember the problem about,
what's the probability that A is older
than B, given that A is older than C?
Similar type of problem,
this being bigger than this is
not independent of this
being bigger than this.
And well we just show that they're not,
if they were independent,
it would be one-fourth.
But I just argued in two different
ways that it's one-third.
So with two correct arguments, I got
one-third and with one incorrect argument,
I got one-fourth.
>> [LAUGH]
>> So I'm gonna go with the one-third.
>> Now we can use symmetry, as long as
we're careful to distinguish between the
intermediate points, and the endpoints.
There are n-2 intermediate points,
each of them is one-third probability.
That is the expected value of,
remember the fundamental bridge?
The expected value of an indicator
is the probability of the event.
The probability of
the event is one third for
each of these intermediate coordinates.
Lastly we just have to look at these two
end points, so there's two of them and
for those it's just one-half because it
was equally likely that this number is
bigger than this number, versus this
number being bigger than this number.
So for the end point, it's one-half
because there's only one neighbor.
So those are both one-half.
So it's just n minus 2 over 3 plus 1,
which we could simplify a little bit.
n plus 1 over 3
So it's basically again a one line thing.
Once you set up the indicators and
you understand your linearity and
your symmetry.
Let's just check does this make sense
in extreme cases, well if n equals
1 that's a really stupid problem you just
have one number and it's a local maximum.
So that's why I assume n is at least 2.
Now let's just quickly check
what happens if n is 2,
then we either have 1 2, or 2 1.
And either way that's one maximum and
this says it's equal to 1.
So that worked and let's see.
This grows linearly and
it goes to infinity as n goes to infinity.
I guess that would be a little bit
weird if they expect a number of max.
So I did not go to infinity
as goes to infinity.
So we do a couple of quick
little checks like that.
But anyway, that's the argument.
So it's those same tools we
were talking about last time.
Just use those in combinations,
indicators, linearities,
symmetry, and
you can solve some really hard problems.
All right, so
let's do one more famous example that
does not involve indicator random
variables cuz I don't want you to think
that's everything there is to expectation.
So this one is called, sorry.
This is called the St. Petersburg Paradox.
And we can debate whether
it's really a paradox or not.
Well, it's not a paradox,
as I've said before.
There's not any true paradoxes, but
that's what it's traditionally called.
And it is something that makes you think,
which is why we're doing it.
This is about thinking.
So here's the problem.
So someone offers you the following game.
They're going to flip a fair coin over and
over again until the coin lands heads for
the first time.
Now if the coin lands heads on
the first trial, you'll get $2,
if it's the second trial for the first
outcome of heads If it's the second
trial you got four dollars, if it's
the third trial you got eight dollars, and
the fourth trial you got 16 dollars and
it doubles every time, okay?
So you get, let's say
a two to the x dollars,
where x is the number
of flips of the coin.
Until it land heads
first H including the H.
So that's what we call
the first success distribution.
So it's a geometric distribution plus
one cuz we're counting that success,
including the success.
And the question, so
obviously if you're playing this game,
you're hoping that the coin will
land tails for a long time.
Cuz this keeps doubling every time,
and the longer it goes on,
the better it double.
It grows exponentially fast,
like If x is 10 then you'll get $1,024 and
so on, it keeps doubling.
So the question is how much should you
be willing to pay to play this game?
Now some people have moral or
other objections to gambling or
are very risk averse or whatever and some
people are gambling addicts and so on.
But let's define fair,
a standard definition of a fair game would
be well what value, you know you should
obviously pay something to play this game
because your going to get some money out.
What value would make peace?
What price would make
the expected value zero,
okay, that would often be
called the fair price.
Although whether you
actually want to pay that or
not depends on your own
gambling preferences.
Okay, so that's the problem.
So it's a It's a very simple
sounding problem, right?
It's just here's the payoff, two to the X,
and then how much should you pay to play.
So, I'm curious what your
intuitions are on this problem,
especially if you haven't
seen this problem before.
But, even if you have, so
let's suppose now I don't want any of you
to gamble away everything a go bankrupt,
right, so let's assume that everyone
in this room is a billionaire, so
you can afford to pay a lot
if you want to play, okay.
So let's assume that everyone
has a billion dollars.
And we could do a little bit auction and
see who'd pay the most here.
So is anyone willing to pay more than
$1 million to play this game once?
Okay, two of you, okay.
$10 million?
$100 million?
You guys really wanna play this game?
You have a lot of faith in me, right?
Yeah because I might just walk
away with your 100 million right?
So that's one assumption we need
is that the person offering this
game is 100% reliable and it's not like
if by chance X was some large number,
then that guy is gonna flee the country
rather than pay you, But okay,
let's assume we can completely rely- okay
so you'll pay a hundred million dollars.
Now probably most people
in this room would not pay,
assuming you have a billion,
most of you would not pay,
I only saw a few hands,
would not pay a hundred million.
How many of you would pay more than
a thousand dollars to play this game once?
Assuming you had a billion so it's not
like a thousand is not that big deal.
But on the other hand, you know,
even if you have a billion you
wanna make more money right so.
All right not too many of you
have above more than $100.
Okay, all right, more than $20?
Okay, so that's interesting.
So there is no right or
wrong answer, necessarily.
Now let's do the calculation.
What is this?
The expected value.
So let's let y equal two to the x.
That's your payoff.
And we want to find
the expected value of y.
Well, that's just pretty
easy by the definition.
Expected value of y all we have
to do is sum up the value times
the probability of that value.
Now in this case y is
always a power of two.
All right so
we're gonna sum overall powers of two.
So, we're gonna sum K equals to infinity.
The value it could take is
two to the k for sum k.
Now the probability of that happening,
this event,
is when the coin lands tails
k- 1 times and then heads.
That has probability,
we're assuming it's a fair coin.
So that's probably one over two to the k.
Because that's one specific event.
So what we're really doing is
summing up one from one to infinity.
What does it mean to sum up one?
That means that we're adding
up 1 + 1 + 1 + 1 forever.
So that's infinity.
So according to that calculation
you should be willing to pay
an infinite amount of
money to play this game.
And yet most of you did not
want to pay more than $100.
So there's something there
that needs to be sorted out.
So okay, so what can we say about that?
Well, It's kind of hard to argue
with this calculation, right?
I mean, this is not some tricky sum where
I'm likely to get messed up somehow.
This 1 + 1 + 1 forever = infinity.
It's pretty indisputable.
So what's going on?
Well if you look this up online I mean
you can find hundreds of pages of
debate about this but
I think the simplest explanation is just
in the real world no one has
an infinite amount of money.
That there is some bound, okay?
Now let's consider the same problem
where we impose some upper bound.
So suppose that you're never gonna get
more than a trillion dollars from this.
Okay, and then let's see what happens.
So if we bounded at one trillion.
And just to make the math easier,
two to the tenth is 1,024,
so that's a little bigger than 1,000.
A trillion is ten to the 12
which is 10 cubed to the fourth.
So if we take two two the 40th
that will be over a trillion.
We may as well just use a power of two.
So then let's assume, what happens
if the game lasts longer than this?
Either there's two possibilities
that we can consider.
One would be that the guy
offering this game just say,
sorry I only have two
to the 40 of dollars.
I mean, that is more than a trillion.
So.
You know, you should be happy
with your trillion dollars.
You shouldn't complain too much, right?
You've got the trillion.
The other possibility you might consider
is if it goes beyond this point,
then he flees the country and
you've got nothing.
Okay?
So let's just consider
either of those two options.
Suppose that we balance at two to
the 40th then what we would get, the same
looking sum but let's suppose first
that he flees the country in that case.
Same sum except now I'm
just gonna go up to 40.
Two to the k, one over two to the k.
Well I'm adding 1+1+1 40 1s that's 40.
So that's the big difference there
$40 instead od infinity dollars.
Just by even imposing a band of a trillion
dollars it sounds like that's a It's
unbelievably unlikely that the game
would last to that point anyway right.
And a trillion dollar is this astronomical
in saying the amount of money and
yet it still reduces it only $40.
Which doesn't seem paradoxical at all.
And if we consider the other, so here
basically I've just cut it off at 40 and
set all the other terms to zero.
If instead we just stuck in a two to
the 40th for all the rest of the terms
those terms are just gonna add up to.
Because the first term beyond this,
if we replaced it by two to
the 40th it would be one half.
And the next one would be one quarter.
And it would go like that.
Those would add up to one.
So that would add $1, so this is
the case where he flees the country.
If he doesn't flee the country and
pays off your trillion dollars,
then it's worth $41 instead of $40,
so you got an extra dollar there.
Okay.
So, a very important cautionary example of
this is that the expected value of
two to the x, this is just going back
to the general case again, the expected
value of two to the x is infinity.
A common mistake would be to just
kind of move the e around and
just stick the e up in the exponent.
So if we look at two to the e of x,
remember I said that for
the first success,
the expected value is one over p which
in this case is two,
so this would be four.
So if you just carelessly
put the e up there,
thought just move the e around,
the average of the power,
the power of the average or something
you will get $4 instead of infinity.
So this is actually not equal.
You can't just move the E
around blindly like that.
What you can do is use linearity, okay?
I mean in general linearity is true.
This is false so
you got to be careful of that.
All right.